[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to our
anthem review I'm John Luke I'm joined
by our reviewer Callie hi that's me this
is something new we've been trying out
it's more of a discussion formats if you
want to see the full review you can go
read it over at gamespot.com it's very
good oh thank you so Callie you gave
anthem a six out of ten I sure did which
is a fair and we'll get into that first
what is anthem the game right not the
beginning anthem anthem is interesting
because it's kind of broken up into two
disparate game parts so you have the the
Bioware esque story portion so there is
like you know a heavy story focus lots
of cutscenes stuff going on and then you
have the loot shooter destiny like kind
of structure to it and so you're going
you know between story stuff on for
tarsus which is your base of operations
into missions and then back to port
arses kind of like at a regular clip
this is the basic structure you are you
know like a freelancer which is a
loosely defined kind of like hero type
yeah
who wears a mech suit called a javelin
there's four different types of those
and that's the basic on paper gist I
think the elevator pitch okay so let's
start with the story because this is a
bioroid game and that's usually the
reason people really gravitate towards
Meyer games how does the story hold it's
difficult right it's it's hard
everything about this game is like you
have one step forward two steps back or
there's like something good and it's
broken up by something not so good the
story is like that too so the the main
campaign the launch story is very
difficult to follow you know there's
it's less like sci-fi and more space
fantasy in that there's a lot of you
know made-up terms and just a lot of
like you know like instead of scientists
they're called arcanists and you know
they're there's a lot of stuff like that
in the game it becomes very difficult to
follow because you kind of need like a
translator to understand what's going on
they do have that there's a codex but
the world-building is you know not
delivered very well so like it's like oh
go here and silence this shape or relic
and
I don't know what a shaper is the
freelancers along with the Sentinels
guardians of the walls protected free
mark and its people from the chaos of
our world until one day the Dominion
arrived on their doorstep cruel
conquerors from the the the setup is
very rocky there's this like heavy
exposition dump a lot of jargon you know
it's a it's kind of like a typical like
there's a vague impending doom and evil
thing going on right and then there's
like the underdog hero ready to approve
themselves and that's you but you know
by the same token you have kind of the
the semblance of what a Bioware
character is in a lot of the characters
in the game both the like main cast and
the side characters so like it's
difficult because I think the story does
a great disservice to those characters
you know you kind of like your partner
in freelancing Owen who is more complex
like I don't know if you talked to him
and he tells you about his childhood and
how his parents had to like basically
sell him off and stuff like there's
there's interesting world building in
those conversations but it's so buried
and so you don't really get a good sense
of those characters and your connection
to those characters doesn't have room to
grow or develop so for example there's
two characters in the tutorial mission
which takes place two years before the
events of the main games there's just
like two year time skip those characters
are I mean you're a rookie at that point
in time in the there's not like an
established connection to those
characters there's this one moment where
you seem like you might be friends and
then two years on they hate you
and I'm like I don't even know what I
did like I you know the drama that's not
earned when there's emotional you know
that could have been an emotional payoff
but just doesn't quite get there cuz
you're like I didn't have enough time to
to really get to know these characters
so it's you know at this push and pull
of like I want to like this character
like Owen I think we were all talking
while we were playing like Owen is your
like Oh Owen yeah and there's like a
mailbox I don't know this is something I
had
you guys about there's a mailbox in the
game and you can read messages from
different characters and they they just
tell you about their lives and stuff and
it's really charming but I got you know
it's just like it's like oh I
you were almost if you had more time if
we just had more time together I could
have loved you kind of thing yeah
and that's that's the the short of it I
think right and that's like the main
story but then in four tarsals kind of
acts like like in Mass Effect there's
like the Normandy where you go around
and you talk to people and you have
these like evolving side conversations
and it seems like those characters are
like where the writing really shine yeah
like I think that's what I mean by like
this game kind of buries it it it buries
the lead a lot do you have this like
heavy exposition and these crazy words
and then you just talk to people in for
tarsus and they're these little micro
stories of just relatable human things
like there's a woman who whose daughter
has been missing for years and she's you
know you can extend this kindness to her
and I don't even like that's something I
don't want to spoil like I want people
to talk to her because I thought it was
really touching and there's just little
moments and you know I kind of want to
like grab onto those moments and hold
onto them because I really did like a
lot of those characters they're all to
me I liked the acting I liked how
expressive they were there's you know
Kristen Schaal who's Louise and Bob's
Burgers she's comedian a bunch of stuff
like she's a character and her character
is really cute and funny I'm listening
what do you have really
you know why because their main
competitor just closed up shop why'd
they do that I'm just learning the
regulator game but my uncle Ronnie said
you know there's good stuff there but
then you're like how much time do you
spend in Fort taursus between going to
missions and you know it's it's
difficult and that's that's where the
game runs into some problems right so
the stuff in for tarsus ends up being at
odds with the gameplay specifically the
coop right so yes the general structure
of the game is like you you start on for
Tarsus you launch a mission then you
come back to for Tarsus there's no way
to like launch a second mission there's
free play but like that's pre play it's
like loosely structured you're not
getting much story out of that right
but if you're playing with friends you
know like we were playing together and
we're playing at a group on discord and
every like five or so minutes someone
would be like oh sorry guys I'm gonna
cutscene or sorry guys I'm talking to
somebody and we'd have to like keep
telling each other to be quiet which is
awkward right so it's weird because like
for half the game you want your friends
there and for half you don't so this the
Hat the part that you don't really need
people there's the story stuff and like
you miss out on a lot of those
conversations if you're like playing
with friends and you know everyone's
just like okay let's get ready to launch
the next mission and then you feel bad
you're like oh sorry wait for five
minutes while I talk to a person you end
up skipping a lot of those conversations
I think you out of everybody we played
with you took the most time to talk to
people but that's because you were doing
that you know on your own time not when
we're playing together and they're the
reaction times where I muted you guys in
discordant so your conversations yeah it
feels bad like you know you want to hang
out with your friends but then when you
get into the missions when you get into
like the actual like loot shooter kind
of gameplay right then you do want your
friends and that's just at odds so yeah
because you can play it solo for the
most part but the game really does
encourage you to play with friends yeah
like when you set yourself to solo
there's like privacy settings when you
go into missions it'll tell you like are
you sure you want to do that solo
because it's better to play with friends
and like loading screen tips tell you to
play with people and that works in game
play but like I said doesn't work very
well when you're trying to get that
story stuff going yeah so let's talk
about the gameplay then because that
seems to be the highlight of the game
yeah like I think flying I think is
something that everybody around here
really really enjoyed doing
flying for me was the best part because
you can just kind of like zip up into
the air and take in everything from
below and Bob and we even go into
waterfalls and go underwater and do all
this cool stuff and that's where you
flying is so emblematic of my problem
with anthem is that like you your suit
can overheat
and you can cool down by flying under a
waterfall for example and then keep
flying and it's cool but the map does
not necessarily always have that
available to you and you will have to
very often go on to the ground to cool
down and then you have to interrupt your
flight all the time that's just what
happens throughout the whole game it's
like you have this really cool moment
and then you have to stop it to do some
some BS let's say but like combat I
think is really fun at its heart
the weapons themselves are like not
super exciting it's not like you know a
lot of people compare this game to
destiny it's not like destiny where like
the shooting just feels so freakin good
the guns are like serviceable shotguns
for example like I felt they like kind
of didn't do anything but the real thing
that shines is the abilities that your
javelins have my favorite is storm which
is like the mage class I think a lot of
us played storm because you can like
chain these elemental attacks like
freeze an enemy and then like smashing
with a fireball and they kind of explode
and it's like it's really cool and if
you're doing that with your friends like
you as you know storm for example can
freeze somebody and then you know like
somebody else can come in and hit them
as another character and that creates
this like chaotic battlefield in it it
gets really exciting and I think the the
loot shooter part of this game that
works really well is you're always
getting new loot you go back to fort
Tarsus you change your loadout and then
you go into the next mission to
experiment with your loot and that's
really fun cuz you can experiment with
different combinations different
abilities like I would get an ability
that I really I don't even know this
existed but now I can throw frost shards
at enemies and that's cool like that
that core is very cool then you know you
run into problems when okay we're all
gonna have to wait for each other during
our you know loading screens at fort
Tarsus and then we you know I have to
update my loadout but Gentiles gonna go
talk to somebody and somebody else is
gonna go do this and then you know
you're there for 10 minutes and then you
go into a mission for 10 minutes so it's
just chopped up but I do think like
there's there's a good like seed of of
game playing in combat in there so
Anthony on Twitter was wondering about
like mission variety like what you're
actually doing within the missions do
you feel like there's a good variety of
what you're doing that's a really good
question it's something I didn't talk
about in my my text review the mission
structure is largely the same like you
you fly somewhere you shoot some stuff
you maybe like get an item that lets you
unlock a thing you know like kind of
sort of like a puzzle but not really a
puzzle more of like a task and then you
go on and shoot more thing as many
runner wraps up that structure to say I
think what keeps it keeps that variety
going is the
you know changing your abilities and
trying new things you know you know if
you're playing it's intercepted I'm
playing a storm like ooh how can we
combine our abilities to do to do cool
things like that's what keeps it from
feeling repetitive to me I played for a
good amount of time and I didn't feel
like it was just a mindless repetitive
grind in the combat it was more like the
actual missions were just a background
for the cool stuff you can do with your
abilities frytss do you feel like the
game there's a lot of depth to the
combat do you feel like the game does a
good job explaining that at times
no there's technical terms for some of
the abilities you have that are just not
ever explained and they're not into any
tutorial that I could find so some
abilities are primers and some are
detonators and combining those is how
you get combos I mean you you get a
sense having played many video games how
combos work you're like oh you freeze
somebody and then they shatter that's a
combo you get a sense of it so it's not
something that necessarily needs to be
like super explained but I didn't even
know that there were terms for the
different kinds of
abilities it was just but you know
honestly like I kind of had fun
experimenting anyway and taking that
away was like sure oh I just need to
test stuff so wasn't it a huge problem
but I was very surprised to learn that
there were actual names for things so uh
this game is a Live service evolving
game and so inevitably everyone always
brings up the end game games like this
do you feel like there is enough there
at rate that launch to be sustainable
something you want to come back to
that's a difficult question because like
with this entire game there's two parts
to it there's story and game like
continuing story and then there's
gameplay end game and the gameplay end
game is not super compelling it's a
complete you know X amount of contracts
an X amount of this kind of mission an X
amount of this kind of mission and
that's just like a grind out the same
missions a bunch of times to ostensibly
get better loot but then where do I use
that better loot because like the
combats very exciting it's bombastic but
then you get to a boss
battle like that would be kind of my
idea of like a high tier more endgame
sort of like goal is to like fight
harder enemies right yeah but the the
boss is right now like most of them have
fire attacks that like overheat your
suit and then you can't fly and like
being able to float and like fly out of
combat as you combining your movement
with those abilities is what makes it
exciting so the boss battles are just so
underwhelming this is like I don't
really have a place right now to loot to
use any cool loot that I get like
there's no incentive for me to like get
a masterwork version of a weapon because
it's not that different from the weapons
I already have and where am I going to
use it but on the other side there is a
cool like post-credit scene that was the
most intriguing story beat in the game
which you take that as you will but like
I saw that it was like oh I'm I want to
know more about that but of course
that's not in the game yet
so I'd have to wait to see what you know
what any update could be
so the other big thing that is a big
talking part of this game is the bugs
this game is in yeas early access period
and Mike on Twitter wanted to know if
you felt like that hurt your overall
experience and that if even if the game
was to patch all the bugs which they did
just do a big day one patch so they have
fixed decent matter it's about to go
into as of this recording about to go
into full launch exactly like even if
all that stuff was gone like would your
opinion of the game still kind of remain
the same yes and that's a really good
question because I kind of like I
mentioned the technical problems at the
very end of my review because you know
my general philosophy was reviews it's
like technical issues exist game
development is hard and those things can
be patched out and like in my experience
generally it's it's a pretty smooth
process to patch a lot of those issues
out right and like with a live game
you're gonna have server issues and
stuff like that what's more important to
me is how the game is designed the
mechanics the story things that are part
of like the overall game design if
that's flawed then like bugs aren't
going to change my general opinion like
I could handle somebody's arm clipping
through a wall which I saw or you know
my customized javelin colors being reset
on for some reason which happened or
audio drops which were frustrating but
that doesn't change how the game
presents itself and like as a story as a
loot shooter how those things don't work
together the conflicting ideas like
technical issues don't change any of
those things and so that's what I really
considered for my review do you think
the this game has the potential to
eventually improve that like will have
its taken king moment like that destiny
one had where it dramatically changed
the game in a way that improved it for a
lot of people that's hard to say right
cuz like the Bioware has said like they
want to continue supporting the game
there's more stuff planned but you know
I we don't know yeah that's the hardest
thing is like that that post-credit
scene was like oh I'm interested to see
what they have planned for that but how
will that fit in with this world that
was not the world building is you know
it
very confusing will that fit in with
these characters that like I have kind
of weird relationships with where like
the relationship I have with an in-game
like my player relationship to them is
much shallower than like my presumed
characters inner like relationship with
them like there's a bunch of things that
would need to be ironed out and I am
intrigued to see like there's there are
good things in the scheme there's things
I like about this game and it could be
it could be cool to see how the
continuing support can't affect those
things yeah so that kind of leads into
our final Twitter question from Jessica
who was wondering about should online
multiplayer games like this be reviewed
with a different like rubric because
it's tough to like games like these and
change all the time and like how do you
handle that with a review yeah that
that's a super good question you know
cuz a lot of games that are you know
games as a service or live games like
this do you have rocky launches which we
did talk about but overall like you know
this is a game that is out right it you
can spend money on it which is not the
most important thing but like the
general public can play this game and so
as a critic I have to evaluate what's in
front of me this is something like you
know I review destiny as well for
GameSpot destiny kind of has these like
ongoing tweaks and then you know set
expansions and I can review those
expansions and kind of continue to
evolve my opinion some games might
require you know looking at them
potentially updating the review or re
reviewing a game because it's changed so
significantly that's things that as the
reviews editor that I do think about so
with anthem it's one of those things
that like I can see this game changing
significantly over its lifecycle like it
very well could and I can't cross that
bridge until I come to it so I do have
to to wait and see
and I it's something I'm very open to
and I'm interested in seeing how this
game changes so I'm interested in
re-evaluating it down the road but I
don't think it requires a different
rubric necessarily just kind of an
ongoing approach or a different approach
to like what does a final review mean is
the review always final is and for me I
think the conversation is ongoing which
is kind of the philosophy behind this
review format to
is something that I just want to
continue to look at what do you say
freelancer make it worth your while
Owen looks like the freelancer is right
again well us anyway
excuse me I just got it that is
excellent and will then run my
Diagnostics let me know when you're
ready to leave
it was a pleasure
all right so that's your overall
impressions of anthem you gave it a 6
out of 10 which is a fair mm-hmm that's
the word for 6 yep sounds like there's a
lot of good things and then a lot of
things that kind of get in the way yeah
just good things that don't really mesh
well together but the good ideas mm-hmm
all right well thanks for watching this
guy's as we said before this is our new
review format that we're trying out so
please let us know what you think of it
in the comments below and for more
reviews stay tuned to game spot
[Music]
you